ja ähm unser nächster Gast steht an und
es ist niemand geringeres als Christoph
krachten der ist natürlich jetzt noch
nicht da der kommt gleich mit dem
Flugzeug Business Class ihr müsst vor
allem daran denken den infotex lesen ihr
müsst den Infotext natürlich lesen und
äh könnt ihr Dienstag klicken und mal
durchlesen auch auf die Links klicken
und euch das auch mal durchlesen
und und am besten ein Video Frage
stellen stellt doch am besten eine
videofrage dazu und ähm kreativ sollten
sein und wenn die kreativ seid dann habt
ihr auch eine Chance dass die Frage in
die Sendung kommt genau und eigentlich
dann dann drücke ich immer die Daumen
ich drück die Daumen